hallo mein Name ist Luca meine Damen und
Herren ihr seht es bereits im Titel
eingeblendet denn Sandra und ich mache
heute mal wieder eine nicht lachen
Challenge mit tiktok-videos hat 739,8
Millionen
7700000 herzlich willkommen hier im
Zeppelin Museum Friedrichshafen heute
möchten wir Ihnen ein ganz besonderes
Exponat vorstellen und zwar diese
Luxuslimousine hier diesen Gaylord
Gladiator
[Musik]
verstehst nicht
ja meine Mutter ist auch nicht mehr da
und jetzt mein Dad so krank ich kann gar
nicht beschreiben was ich
alles fühle das glaube ich dir gerne
so Leute ist fertig runtergeladen
eigentlich
dieses Video hat mir die Augen geöffnet
weil ich meine Augen davor zu hatte und
um das Video zu sehen habe ich sie
aufgemacht danke Anke und Sibylle
erstmal Sonnenschein am Ende immer lacht
meine beste Freundin damals sie Brille
180.000 €. okay kaufen wir
wie viel kostet das Haus
[Musik]
es war so krass guter Vergleich einfach
so ein starkes tiktoko
schneller
singen auch irgendwie komisch
Outfit ist so günstig also ja Mausi das
sieht man aber auch
die Mausi eigentlich sieht man es gar
nicht und ich dachte wir wollen Frauen
nicht mehr dafür schämen oder sich
anziehen nur weil du dann weitermachen
dran hängst wird es dadurch ein witziger
nur weil viele Leute lachen wird morgen
in dieser salonfähig
bist du Rapperin oder was los
ich feier den so heftig
also ich könnte mir vorstellen vieles zu
machen ich bin sehr sehr spontan aber
ich finde es wichtig dass der Mann so
ein bisschen das ganze leitet dass ich
einfach sage komm ich hole Dich ab dann
würde ich mit dir wahrscheinlich in die
Bibliothek fahren
für das erste Date damit du die Fresse
hältst
[Musik]
gut
ich habe selten schlau gehabt ne das ist
total dämlich
ey man merkt richtig wir uns auf Humor
bei solchen Sachen auseinander geht
ich glaube da muss man ein neuer
Fernseher hier
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
was bestellt sich ein Idiot beim
Italiener
[Musik]
die sehen sich irgendwie ähnlich
es
ist eine Sache ganz wichtig
eine Sache ist ganz wichtig
die habe ich das vergessen 24
ja willst du Kinder heiraten
Kinder heiraten
ja
der links einfach das einfach rezo für
arme irgendwie ne
[Musik]
ed
ich schwöre
nein
komplett verschwunden
[Musik]
dicker echt ähm ihr habt keine Worte
mehr dafür
[Musik]
[Applaus]
du bist der Mann du musst du hast als du
mich geheiratet hast gesagt du wirst
immer für mich da sein
[Musik]
ich bin so gerne die Geissens persönlich
kennenlernen ich würde sogar Geld dafür
bezahlt
wir wollen eine Podcast Folge mit den
aufnehmen das wäre so krass lustig zwei
Fische
[Musik]
der
andere wo
ja das ist dein Humor Vorsicht spielende
Kinder
Sandra das hat nichts zu tun heute abend
entspannen zocken mit den Jungs aber
nein die Frau guckt m auf jeden Fall ihr
UPS Jungs auf jeden Fall nicht ändern
ja
sorry das ist richtig gut das letzte
vorbereitet habe ist jetzt keins wo man
wirklich lachen muss sondern eins was
einen sondern Nostalgie Stimmung so ein
bisschen versetzt
[Musik]
war einfach früher Digger
oder war deine Kindheit nicht so
wie denn
auch beenden wenn es euch gefallen hat
das gerne einen Daumen hoch und dein
Video hier da abonniert
einfach nicht dicker scheiß auf die
Glocke scheiß auf alles bei bye
[Musik]